the Joe Rogan experience don't listen to
me first of all get your medical advice
from me yeah well no I I had already had
the zinc eye but that confirmed that I
was taking zinc so our kids a couple
articles you should read on it yeah it's
very good taking vitamins multivitamin
bytom ins and then honestly I'm not
drinking as much you know unfortunately
YouTube said that they're gonna take
down anything that doesn't coincide with
the World Health Organization's ruling
on you know what to do about this
pandemic what do you mean their YouTube
is taking down things and now I don't
know how specific they're gonna be about
this but they were saying alternate
therapies like vitamin C and things
along those lines which is kind of
unfortunate mmm because like unless
they're not being that strict about it
because I would say if someone was
saying howdy if somebody made a video
someone who's a nutrition expert and
they made a video how to protect your
mount immune system from ko vid 19 or
maybe just protect your immune system
during the time of kovat 19 so I'm
saying that it's protecting it from that
but how to how to boost up your immune
system in this very dangerous time in
terms of viral infections well there's
there are strategies there's things you
can do like get more sleep drink more
water eat healthier and keep your body
healthy with nutrients and making sure
you're eating clean and don't drink
alcohol and don't smoke cigarettes if
you just do those things like this is
real if this has actually been proven
mmm-hmm
so I don't know what you can get away
with saying and what you can't get away
with saying but you can't always just
hope that doctors come up with a cure
because yes the doctors are going to
come up with a cure and yes we need them
to do that but you can't always think
that medicine is going to fix you and
you could just keep doing what you've
always been doing that got you sick in
the first place
because a lot of times when you get sick
it has to do with how you've been living
not always but a lot of times like is
your immune system already compromised
or are you the already weak are you
beating up your body and abusing it and
then BOOM
then you catch a cold mm-hmm we all know
that's true so advice on how to
strengthen your immune system says it's
important for
buddy now if you want people to say
don't say that this is a cure for kovat
19 it's gonna keep you from getting
Kovan 19 fine great so what like
YouTube's gonna take a video down that
says this what I'm saying like if you've
item ins don't don't don't drink alcohol
or during the time if it has to do with
coronavirus and it's contrary or not in
what the World Health Organization is
recommended which changes every two
weeks
well they [ __ ] up there's where
happens don't wear masks wear masks
don't wear masks good to wear masks bad
to wear masks with if somebody posted it
on their Twitter the other day from it
might have been Donald Trump jr. but
showed world health or nose on Instagram
World Health Organization tweet from
them from it was I guess it was what
time it was last year I think it was
last i think is december or maybe the
beginning of this year but they were
saying that the world health
organization says that it cannot be
contracted from person to person
mmm this is a tweet that they put out
mm-hmm so you can't say how the hell do
you get at them well they didn't know
that directly from a Pangolin yeah yeah
have to be there so don't worry about it
this is what they were getting Chinese
propaganda they were spreading it but
the World Health Organization when they
were posting it that was that's
absolutely wrong we all know that's
absolutely wrong so if you say you have
to listen to what the World Health
Organization says well they've been
wrong before right and I want to know
how much they really know about
nutrition how much they really know
about health and fitness like I'm
looking at these people they don't like
the healthiest humans in the world just
fish someone's a scientist you know
saying doesn't mean they're taking care
of their own body that's a problem smart
guy but he might not work out and I've
talked to a lot of really brilliant
people including doctors they eat shitty
food and don't really work out
[Applause]